mary mccartney she's a daughter of
beatles legend paul mccartney she's
launching a new cooking show
she's a cookbook author she's a
photographer she's hoping to make
vegetarian dishes easy and accessible
she says
it's called mary mccartney serves it up
her friends include actresses kate
hudson and cameron diaz
make virtual appearances to share
recipes stories and the food that they
love
i was invited mary knows i can't cook so
i gotta
got to make a sunshine mocktail i could
even do that
in this clip mccartney creates meatless
marinara subs with musician mark ronson
i i realize that you're treating me a
bit like a
three-year-old but i also like the i
this looks so good i'm not gonna
complain yeah
now we just put the top on it get the
top on that sandwich
kind of squish it down or not this is
gonna be so
messy to eat yeah you can only eat this
with friends or on your own
it's it's beautiful though so there we
have it
let's compare mine's a little bit messed
here like kind of falling out of the
side but
it's got character yeah
that's what you want character in your
sandwich i could always i could listen
you talk
all day mary mccartney it's called
serves it up it airs on the streaming
service discovery plus
she joins us first on cbs this morning
mary good morning to you it's so good to
see you
good morning here you have snow in new
york
yes i know you should see it mary it's
it's big big big
giant giant giant mounds of snow but
we're managing we're okay
we're a hearty lot here in new york i'm
drinking a gale sunshine so i'm thinking
of sunnier days oh
thank you thank you this is the thing
mary when you first called me about the
show i said mary i don't cook i'm not a
vegetarian you said
that's okay and i said well why would i
come on why do you want to have me on
what are we going to do you said
it's all about the conversation gail
it's all about that
and having fun along the way
exactly and i said it's my cooking show
so i'm going to cook for you
yeah you don't have to cook for me
you're my guest and this is what mary
did guys
she sent all of the food because i
thought there's no way i can do this
she sent all of the food fully prepared
all i had to do was take it out and put
it on a plate i could do that
so you sent three cameras because
everything was done remotely so alexis
my assistant had to set up three
different cameras i couldn't believe
what you pulled off you're in london
and i'm in my kitchen in new york and
you describe your vegetarian recipes as
healthy
but not righteous i was a little nervous
mary because i always feel
vegetarians are very judgmental of us
people that like a good burger but you
said nope
that's not this kind of party explain
what you mean by that
um i think mary mccartney serves it up
is
is really um devised for people that are
meet with juices so
i grew up in a vegetarian family and we
promote meat-free monday which is like
going
veggie for one day plant-based living on
a monday one day a week to sort of help
your carbon
footprint and it's really something
everyone can do to make a difference
and i found that lots of people were
saying well i want to eat less meat but
i don't know what to cook
so i've grown up in that kind of family
so i
am always about giving meal solutions
and recipes i sort of want to hold your
hand and
to take you through the process and
inspire you not tell you off and judge
you
kind of just say look let's do it i
don't want you to judge me and i'm not
going to judge you
yeah did you have a conversation at home
that changed your way of thinking
no i mean if anything i found growing up
that when i left home and i'd be at
dinner parties someone would be sitting
next to me and they'd see i'd be eating
veggie and they go
are you vegetarian what you know and
start like getting at me like do you do
this and like and i was like i'm not
telling you what to eat let's let's
chill out here so
over the years what is so exciting is
that has changed and it's like there's
open conversation about food and where
food comes from
so i think my role is to and literally
people are like i just want
ideas of what to cook something quick
easy meat-free
and that's where i come in uh hey mary
no thanks
oh i was gonna say christmas anthony
it's tony decouple here uh we we're a
big cooking household we're very excited
for the show we already watched a lot of
discovery network
uh i have a question related to one of
your kitchen essentials and anthony's
already laughing at me here but
one of your kitchen essentials in fact
number one is a toaster
now my wife and i have a debate running
about whether the toaster
should always be on the counter or be
put away
after use and i'm wondering could you
clear up always on
always on the counter yay that's what i
say too
question yes that's what i say here
no i'm like do you need it my and my
reasoning is i'm toast obsessed i'm
sandwich obsessed so
it might be for breakfast with peanut
butter and jelly on it but often at
lunch time i'll like
heat up a soup and just put a piece of
toast in and then
layer it up with things so yeah i need
it at the ready at all times so
sorry to your wife my wife is very happy
that's
great to me yeah she's happy tony's in
trouble yeah i'm sandwich obsessed too i
get that feeling but
mary i want to ask you it's anthony i
want to ask you about one of your other
talents other than cooking which is
photography
you took the cover photograph of your
father and taylor swift for rolling
stone
which is yeah kind of a cool assignment
yes
what was that like well it was
pretty amazing i kind of became dad's
lockdown photographer
during the first lockdown i did the
album cover for mccartney three the
pictures for that too
and then dad was um really sweet he came
up to me and he said we're doing a
rolling stone cover with taylor swift
and he said i'd love you to take the
picture
and he pointed out something i hadn't
thought of he said your mom
was the first female photographer to
have the cover of rolling stone
in the 60s so it sort of all came full
circle so
my two passions are photography and food
when i look at that picture i see that
paul is looking actually directly at you
and i'm wondering when you knew growing
up when did you know growing up that he
was famous and he was a beatle and what
was it like to
be able to blossom around to say dad i
need you to do x y and z
i think i probably realized it when i
got older and we'd be at restaurants
and we'd sort of be all having like a
family dinner
and then people would literally like put
their turn their chairs around and be
looking at us like we were the
entertainment
because apart from that growing up we
like lived in sort of we would go away
to quiet places
so mainly when i got old enough i was
like why is everyone looking at us
so yeah i hid behind the camera for
quite a long time taking pictures and
then
discovery plus contacted me and said
will you do this cooking show so
i'm being brave and stepping in front of
the camera
see gail you don't you are you're scared
of cooking but i'm like
this is this for me is a whole new
experience i am so scared of cooking
i can't do it but i would love for you
to send me that cauliflower number that
you made it was so delicious i'll never
be able to pull it off
i'll use it too i'll make it for you
tony can actually cook so please send it
do you know what was do you know what
was amazing about that because as gail
said she
i texted her and i was like will you be
on my cooking show and she was like mary
i don't cook
please don't ask me to do it please
don't make me and i'm like i'm not gonna
make you cook and you
almost up until we did the face time you
weren't quite
trusting me i trust you mary mccartney i
adore you
and i'm cheering you on did we have the
best time gail
we had the best time thank you anyway
the best thing was
the best thing we got to go after i'm so
[Music]
cheers gail sunshine mocktail we have
posted it
the recipe on our facebook twitter and
our instagram page it's actually pretty
good
i'm gonna get me one